welcome everyone today we'll be
restarting the we'll add another button
and the first talk now will be by Tamir
he will talk about the recent so yes I'm
going to talk about so yeah and so like
I said we construct a new music protocol
based on the assumption and assuming the
existence of trapdoor hash may be one of
the like more exciting bottom line is
also this work or vacations is the first
music from FP NADH which are both
standard assumptions that was not known
to employ music before so this is the a
joint work with chica and then kata and
under start so let me just define define
a sexy real quick so what is necessary
it's not directly zero node protocol so
it's basically a book system where we
have a Krugerrand a verifier and some
statement that an input X is in some NP
language and we're going to assume that
the prover is efficient given an NP
witness for the statement and we're
going to be working in a motel where
both parties have an access to a common
reference string which we assume is
generated in a trusted set up before the
invocation of the pro code and we
require that the protocol is non
interactive and therefore it consists
only of a single message so the prover
is going to send a proof by and the
verifier is going to either accept or
reject and we require the standard
completeness soundness and zero
knowledge requirement so completeness
basically says that if the statement is
true then
the verified accept so if soundness
means that if a statement is false then
even a cheating proving cannot convince
them wait for it that is true and zero
knowledge says that a verified cannot
learn any extra information given the
proof other than the validity of the
statement this is pretty standard
everything here there are many
applications of Music's
and they are like interesting objects
whether themselves I'm not going to
spend a lot more time on discussion of
applications
question ok so before I start talking
about what we do let's kind of survey
that roaches that are known rock music
sumption so maybe the textbook approach
to do that is called the hidden bits
model and the the only known way to
instantiate this this model is using
terms of permutations and as far as we
know we can construct up the
permutations only under factoring
related assumptions so this approach is
still limited in the sense a more recent
line of work construct musics using
groups with bilinear maps so we make a
difficult man style assumptions on these
troops and the constructions themselves
are been on genetically they heavily
rely on linear maps in these groups so
we I don't think there's a ok let's just
proceed so so there are these two
approaches which are kind of limited in
terms of what standard assumptions we
can base their security on at lasting
lastly there's this approach of using
future may transform in order to take a
zero knowledge protocol and turn it into
a zero knowledge I mean many many were
we try to construct in Essex using this
approach in a sound probably sound
manner and and this line of work
eventually led to constructions that are
secure understand the functions this is
a pity new from last year good so our
work is can be kind of put under this in
this framework of constructing musics
using yet Sameer and in order to
accentuate a future million probably
some manner we go through a notion
called correlation stackable hash
superior work could take a stop to
relation that table hash under lwe in
our work we show construction of an is a
protocol on the FBN assumption like I
said using a blush which but sir can be
instantiated on the good are there any
questions so far
okay so let's start discussing this
proto of constructing musics using
collation flexibility so we start with
zero knowledge protocol that consists of
three messages and we assume it's public
: meaning that the very first challenge
in the second message is just random
consists of just random coins and a Fiat
applying the future may transform to a
British protocol means taking some hash
function edge and letting the proof will
emulate the original key message
protocol by himself
so the first message is just computed as
before so let's say that first message
is a so the probe will compute a and
sends it to the verifier and now in
order to conclude the very first
challenge the prover computes the hash
value of a so the verified challenge in
this non-interactive protocol is
essentially the hash of a under a hash
key which is sampling randomly and so
now that the prover has his first
message a and the very first challenge
which is the hash of a you can compute
the fairness the third message and and
send all these messages to the verify
base you can clearly see this protocol
is interactive and if we start with a
public one protocol then you can easily
see that this protocol is also complete
it is also not hard to show that if we
start with an honest verify gene or zero
merge protocol then the v 3h a million
transform preserves zero knowledge ok
and there's no no sense in talking about
and it's verified here because the
protocol is not interactive so we have
compete miss and zero knowledge and all
is left to do is the soundness
so if we start with the three message it
sounds protocol then it's not clear that
the future may transform preserve
soundness for the reason that the proof
has some control over the verifies
challenge so the very first challenge is
no longer sampled by the verifier but is
rather computed by the prover over the
first message so you can think about
that it'll provide that we try to choose
a first message whose hatch gives him a
challenge that will that made let him
cheat and convince the verify that the
statement is true although it's not so
this leads us to focus on a very
specific type of three message protocols
that we call Sigma protocols in a Sigma
protocol if we fix CRS and then input X
and a first a message approvals first
message a then we ask that this exists
only a single verifies challenge that
may possibly allow the group to cheat so
again I'm fixing a CRS and an X that is
not in the language so we have a false
statement here and a first message and
we say that a protocol is a Sigma
protocol if it has a unique but
challenged or in other words if there
exists only a single bad challenge yea
and baibe a challenge we mean it's very
first challenge that and for which there
exists a proof that accepts and based on
the fact that they exist single bad
challenge or unique but challenge we can
define a function that takes that is
defined by the a C or s and input X and
takes input the first message and
outputs the batch energy so I'm going to
refer to this function as the Bachelet
function from now so now we ask when
does the future mere transform preserve
soundness in this case so we can see
that if we can claim that it's hard for
the prover to find a first message a
such that the hash of a HJ is this bad
challenge then it will be hard for the
prover to break the son
because you will never be able to find a
first message and where the where it's
hash which is essentially this very
first challenge is the Bechet and we're
going to call this notion or this
security requirement correlation
intractability so we say that a hash
function is college intractable for the
Bachelet function if it's hard to find
such a name
and questions
good okay so now we have a recipe for
constructing game g6 so first of all we
need a sigma protocol and what else we
need is a correlation tractable hash for
the class of batch challenge functions
if we have this tool we can apply the
future may transform over Sigma protocol
using the collection tractable hash and
get a probably sound so the guiding rule
kind of of this of this approach or in
order to to instantiate this recipe is
to describe the batch challenge as
simple as possible or in other words to
to to make the complexity of the badge
challenge complexity as well as possible
because the lower the complexity of the
bat challenge then intuitively the
simpler the task of constructing inject
ability for these kind of functions
become okay this is a pure intuition
again intuitively shocking crushing
package for simple functions is simpler
so not at asking questions first
question we should ask is how simple
this batch challenge it can be again we
have to start with the Sigma protocol
the protocol that is zero knowledge and
sounds so we cannot just take any
protocol and here so we ask how simple
can a bad challenge function okay single
protocol B and once we know more or less
the answer to this question we also have
to ask what kind of correlation
tractability we can obtain under
standard assumptions so against what
functions we can protect in correlation
to activate - understand the assumptions
good so the first day work that tried to
instantiate this paradigm in a provable
some manner is this work by can I tell
that dates back to 2016 and there they
observe that the bad bad challenge
function is efficiently recognizable so
they say if I give you a Bachelor in
turn you can efficiently recognize it's
a bad challenge and therefore the the
goal of constructing musics reduce it to
the goal of constructing correlation
intractability for such functions and
then they show how to construct relation
intractable - for functions that are
efficiently
organizations that are efficient
recognizable and they do that based on
pretty wild assumptions so they assume
sub-exponential indication and some
other stronger notion of Education this
line of work continues with many
interesting works and again each of
these works a proposed the construction
of question jack table of questions that
will hatch for some class of functions
that captures the badge challenge
function and some measurement protocol
but again all of these protocols they
assume assumptions that are far apart
from being standards a standard in
particular the either assumed
obfuscation or KDM with with the optimal
security very recently in fact last year
we finally this line of work finally led
to constructions under standard
assumptions and so we started with this
work of can I tell where the observation
that the batch challenge can be actually
efficiently computable and some Sigma
protocols and now the God becomes
constellation tractability for
efficiently computable functions and
they show how to do that using
sakura sakura flume commercial chip
eclipse' which can be instantiated under
circulars secure
and then Pike at Sunday Shahan show how
to do that the based only on the plain
elderly
okay so this is the first work that
instantiates the ehm ear for new sex
based on standard assumption good so in
order to try and construct musics under
the other standard assumptions we
observe that all these works they
consider the complexity of computing the
bad challenge okay so now I'm focusing
on these last two words so they focus on
the complexity of computing the bad
challenge and because the bad challenge
can be a general polygon computation
then it seems that the techniques that
we need to consolidation testability I
have to go through some full homework
with some fully homomorphic instructions
so for example here we use a little much
encryption this work essentially relies
on some form of commitments all based on
lwe so we kind of the rich from this one
of work and consider the complexity of
approximating bad challenge so usually
when there's something that's hard to
compute you try to approximate right so
now we focus on the approximation
complexity of bad challenge which is
hopefully much simpler than the
complexity of computing bad challenge
and we hope that by focusing on the
approximation a complexity then maybe we
can make the correlation of that much
easier and we actually show that it is
possible and so particularly we show
that based on the LP an assumption there
are some similar protocols where the
bachelier function can be approximated
using constant degree polynomials
and having this we can now construct
collision tractability for functions
that are approximated by constant degree
polynomials and obtain this X and it
appears that the constructing such
collision attack the trash can be done
using tabbed or hash which can be based
on the HQ RBC oh I see someone raised
the hand
so can you define what approximating the
challenge means sure definitely I'm just
providing a high level overview here I'm
going I'm gonna go through all the
details much granted but again for I
just want to give you the intuition of
why we did is useful in general so again
instead of considering the bad challenge
or it's a its complexity its exact
complexity we consider its approximation
complexity and this allows us to reduce
the task of constructing the occlusion
tractability
from constructing questions our ability
for all officially computable functions
to open stopped and collisions at
availability for functions that can be
simply approximated by constant in April
O'Neill's Thurston degree pool owners
are very very simple object I hope I
answered partially let me see if I
understand so it's not that the so the
the function that you're trying to build
correlation intractability against is
still it's still like the same function
it's the bad challenge function you're
just using instead of like looking at
like a sort of more natural complexity
notion like it should be efficiently it
should be efficiently computable there's
no like this you're using this dis
approximate my constants problem though
though so we we actually take a special
instantiation of this Sigma protocol
under atm
okay so I'm going to talk about it but
in high-level Sigma protocol uses some
commitment scheme and we show that if
this commitment scheme is some
commitment scheme which is based on LP M
then this batch challenge function which
contains
some operations related to this
movements team can be approximated by
constantly putting on okay so this is
not true for every bad challenge
function of any signal protocol any
other questions
okay good let's proceed so before
talking about how to approximate that
challenge separation to build a let me
just convince you the bad challenge can
be even this is even this is not clear
good so my goal now is to show you a
sigma protocol where the efficient batch
challenge is a computable efficient and
now let's keep this outline in mind so
our ultimate goal is constructing is a 4
MP and we show it's not formally but we
explain to you why this goal reduces to
the goal of constructing collation
tablet hash for the bad challenge
function of something Makoto perfect ok
so maybe the first example that comes to
mind when we talk about zero knowledge
or at least one of the first examples is
the zero notes protocol for graph
hamiltonicity so the statement is that
some graph G has a Hamiltonian cycle H
ok and this is an np-complete language
of course so we have a graph G and the
Hamiltonian cycle and edge and the
prover wants to prove to the verifier
than that such a Hamiltonian cycle
exists in G so the first thing that had
proved I do he he chooses a random
permutation PI and applies it over H so
now we have this random permutation of
of H and I remind you HT just a cycle so
this is just a random cycle graph and
now the prover commits on on this graph
next a verifier sample is a random coin
which is a public coin and sends it to
the approval and now there are two cases
so if the challenge is 0 P is equal to 0
then
that prove where he commits to the
entire thing he reveals the pin mutation
on H by H and this period this clearly
reveals nothing right because this is
this is just depend on my cycle on the
other case when e is equal to 1 then the
prover D commits to a subset of the
commitments he sent in the first message
and more specifically he did he commits
to the edges that correspond to none
edges of G so the unless the important
thing to remember is that in the third
message the property commits to
something that was committed on in the
first message and now once the the
commitments are received by the verifier
the verify first checks that the any
commitments are valid and if is equal to
zero then he verifies that the the graph
is indeed a cycle and otherwise if he is
equal to one he checks that what he
received all the commitments to none
edges of 5 of H as well so I'm not going
to go into the details but whether has
seen this then he's probably already
convinced that this is complete sound
and zero knowledge for those of you who
didn't see this before then I know
you're gonna believe me that it's really
hard to it's really easy to show that
these deployments hold so I'm taking
this protocol as as an example for a
more general abstraction that we call a
commit and open Sigma protocol so I'm
going to look at protocols where the
probe will first generate some proof PI
and then commits to to this proof so the
first message of the prover is just the
commitment to do some proof and along
with the proof by the program prepares
two subsets
y 0 and PI 1 so these are two sub
strings of the off PI and now the event
for instance is a public challenge and
once the challenges received the prover
D commits to the substring corresponding
to this
so if the challenge is zero he'd become
it's two pi zero and otherwise he
promised to buy one and in a competent
open Sigma protocols the verification
consists of two verification machines d0
and d1 and verification simply consists
of first verifying that the D
commitments are valid so first a
verifier verifies that the openings are
okay that they are not legitimate and
the next thing he do he runs the
corresponding verification algorithm so
he takes ve and the computer and turns
it over PI e okay so again we can kind
of split the verification into two parts
each corresponding to two one case
depending on the value of the challenge
so why am i bothering to take commit and
open my Sigma protocols and the reason
is that I can kind of describe the bad
challenge function in such protocols
very easily so let's see so what happens
when you unique bad challenge is equal
to zero then by the definition of the
eunuch by challenge cheating prove I
cannot cheat when the challenge is one
right because the batch challenge is
unique and therefore the verification in
the one case must fail so we know that
v1 1 PI 1 is equal to 0 on the other
hand when the unique back challenge is 1
then we know that it's cheating prove I
can cheat in the one case and therefore
a p1 on PI 1 is equal to 1 and now you
can see that the unique match challenge
can be simply computed by running v1 on
PI 1
okay so the batch challenge
corresponding to the CRS X and the
traced message a is if we one invoked 1
PI 1 where PI 1 is the are the values
that are underlying their commitments in
a perfect so it's not clear that in
general this function is computable it's
not clear how to extract by one out of a
but we know that when the commitment
scheme is extractable meaning when we
can extract the committed values out of
the commitment using some a trapdoor
then this function is a computable so we
simply extract PI one using the
extraction algorithm of the underlying
the commitment scheme and then we run
the one which is just pull some polygon
computation so now we know that when we
use a commitment scheme and extractable
commitment scheme underlying this commit
and the open Sigma protocol then the bad
challenge of this protocol is
efficiently computable and this means
that if we have connection tact ability
for all computable functions then we get
music how by simply applying at the pH a
mere transform using this hash function
over commit and open Sigma protocols
wait an extra step in the commitment
scheme and this is essentially what the
what this two words do they construct
collisions activity for all efficiently
computable functions in particular under
lwe any questions
good so now that we are talked a lot
about HM Ian's a question of ability we
haven't really defined what Coalition
has built it is so we said that the hash
function is correlation tractable for
some function f if no adversary can find
a correlation between H and F more
concretely let's define this security
game which we call the create stability
game so in this game we sample a random
hash key K and then we ask the adversary
to give us some input X and that versary
wins if and only if X is the correlation
between H and F meaning that H of X
under this hash key is equal to f of X
so if this game is hard to end then we
say that H is equal a detectable Foley
and we say that H is currency currency
that will for a function plus F if it is
collisions a bit for every function in
the class
any questions regarding this this is
important and the bit this notion is a
bit different than anything at least I
saw in crypto so ok so to get the better
sense about correlation tractability
let's first try and see if it's if it's
an easy tasks sometimes or no if it can
be trivial at all so what happens when
we try to construct relation to activity
for a single function or when our
function class contains a single
function f and the ideas can we easily
construct collation capability in this
case against that ok so it appears that
constructing CI for a single function is
actually easy you can just define your
hash function to be FX plus 1 and it's
clear that HX is never equal to f of X
notice that I didn't even use the hash
key and this idea is actually easy to
generalize when your function class
contains only polynomially many
functions so if your function class is
small then it's easy construct to
construct relation tractability
relation that will have okay so what
happens when your function class f
contains only length expanding functions
so now your class may contain
exponentially many functions but I tell
you that all functions in the class are
length expanding what happens now so
with a piece that also in this case it's
easy construct to construct relation
tractable hash and the construction I'm
suggesting is the following so let the
hash key be just a random string or and
define the hash function to be to just
output all regardless of the input so
the hash function is the constant so
we'd find HX to be just R and this is
I'm saying that is determined by the
hash key and now notice that if if the
function is sufficiently expanding them
with very with the we can claim that
with negligible probability or is even
in the image of it of AF sorry and
therefore there exists no X with
overwhelming probability such that H of
X is equal to or
are these two examples clear
good I'm not getting any questions that
then I assume they are clear but please
do ask if they're not so now we know
that correlation taxability is a
non-trivial task when our functioning
class is sufficiently rich if it
contains many functions and it contains
a betrayal compressing functions so the
case when our functions are expanding is
not interesting and unfortunately or
interestingly the belt the castle baton
functions is such a class so it contains
many many functions and they are
compressing so mystics are non-trivial
anyone doubted they were good ok so I'm
going to discuss an approach towards
constructing coalition intractable -
that was introduced in a period war so
we say the following if we want to
construct a correlation tractable hash
edge then it's sufficient to construct
the hash such that for every F in the
class we have a distribution over hash
keys which is a fake distribution so for
every function there is some fake
distribution over hash keys that is
indistinguishable from the real
distribution over hash keys so we can
sample a key given some app that looks
indistinguishable from the hash key and
what we require from this fake hash key
is the following
so we require that the collation
tractability game when we sample a
random fake hash key rather than a
random real hash key so whether this
game is statistically hard to win
again in this game is identical to the
Croatia tractability game we are except
that we sample a fake hash key so again
we're sampling it k cache key and then
the verse series goal giving this fake
hash key is to find a correlation so his
goal is to find an X such that H with
the fake hash key is equal to f of X
and it's not hard to see that if these
two conditions hold then H is a
correlation tractable for all functions
in the class and this is simply because
if the adversary is able to break the
correlation tractability game that yield
interaction equation to activate the
game for some F then he must have
distinguished between the fake hash key
and the d8 key because the credibility
with the fake hash key is impossible to
win even for an unbounded adversary and
the different way to look at it which is
which may be easier we can switch the
correlation tractable game to the fake
relation tractable game for some F based
on this distribution bility between the
fake ID and the real hash game and now
we can claim the scholarship ability is
hard because this game is statistically
hurtful so now Paul becomes the
following we we aim at constructing a
hash family H such that for every
function in the class we first of all
have a distribution over fake hash keys
which we denote by K sub F and we want
that the correlation tractability game
with K sub F is a sickly hard to win and
in other words we require that there
exists no correlation between H K sub F
and F except for negligible probability
so we want the probability that there
exists at all some X for which H of x is
equal to f of X with this fake actually
is a negligible any questions yes yes so
actually I don't understand the
difference between this fake hash key
the real key so what is really is there
some difference in the function of the
the definition of the hash function or I
don't
yes so it's it's simply a different
distribution of their hash keys so
notice that it's impossible
using some using some statistical
argument argument you can show that it's
impossible to get statistical
correlation tractability for all
functions in class so what this approach
says let's submit a fake hash feeling
which is indistinguishable from the real
hash key distribution and this allows us
to focus our correlation tractability
task to just one function in this class
let me watch the real question this okay
so okay so formally I required that
there exist so this hash key is sampled
according to some distribution there is
some algorithm that samples the key
right yes so I require that there exists
another algorithm that is given a
function f and it outputs a key K sub F
that depends on this function but the
distribution of the fake keys is in the
solution is indistinguishable from the
real keys
okay so the point is is it like in the
in the real protocol is it the case that
I could actually get the real protocol
also with a fake like it's not a
disjoint set right so it could be that
it's the same they are over the same
domain yes yes the hash keys may be a
substitute the real excuse it's not
going to be the case but for exact so
okay in the in the real construction so
what we usually do is that this key K is
some encryption of 0 and K sub F is some
encryption of F okay if if it helps you
to think about this like that then then
maybe actually it may be actually good
way to think about it so okay K can be
simply some encryption of 0 and K sub F
can be encryption of F and semantic
security of the encryption implies the
indistinguishability between the two
distributions
I hope this works any other questions so
I have a question so is it important to
consider statistically hard to win games
or is it okay to also consider
computationally - cubes no if so if I
replace statistically here with
computationally hard to win we still get
declaration tractable - however some
more statistical equality intractability
have some special features so
essentially allows you to to get
statistical lay zero knowledge we don't
get that I can explain later why but yes
if we replace the statistical to win
here with computational to win we still
get the collision tractability but just
the regular question but but then ending
point one is it computationally
indistinguishable artistically
distinguishable no it is computationally
in this solution okay I mean at some
point you have to you have to finish
using all your assumptions right like at
the end of the day your proof has to
terminate so you can so if you if you
make this a computational property -
then you didn't have to prove that that
computational property holds somehow it
just makes makes the border construction
on pool
any other questions cool okay okay I see
there is another question yes oh I just
wanted to mention the statistical
correlation and tractability lets you
get a proof rather than an argument
system right yes if that's what you want
and this is a helpful property for that
yeah I confused okay so yeah it's not
analogous thanks anyway don't get either
so yes cool okay so now we know what
question that ability is we have some
sense how we can approach the problem of
sorting it and I want to talk now about
a new strategy for constructing
coalition tractability okay so I'm going
to take him back to the trivial case of
length expanding functions so again we
have a function that takes a small
domain and expands it to larger range
and I told you about this construction
that simply samples a random R and the
hash function is constant
so it doesn't depend on the input X so
for any input X H of X is simply R and
let's try to kind of take this very
trivial construction and put it inside
the complicated summer statistical COI
paradigm so the fake hash key here would
be just the key and here we have
statistical distribution bility and for
every F we can say that the probability
that there exists a correlation that the
existent X such that H of X is equal to
f of X is simply the probability that
all is in the image of f of X and if
this image is exponential sports
compared to the range then this
probability can be negligible
right so again and therefore we get that
this construction is questions that and
the word idea for constructing concept
ability for general functions is to kind
of impose this picture also when the
function f is compressing so my goal now
is to draw something like this
yes also when the function takes a huge
domain and compress it to a small range
so now our function looks like that and
now we cannot sample a random R and
claim that with negligible probability
it falls in the image of the function
because the image of the function may
possibly cover the entire range so now
our construction will consist of a H of
X we consist of or will use a different
hash function which we were going to
call H Prime and the hash function H
will be simply defined by H prime of X
plus R where R is this random string we
sample like before and which is the part
of the hash key and H prime of X is a
special hash function so what am i gonna
require from H prime so again for all
for every function in the class if I
want that there exist a distribution
over fake hash keys that is
indistinguishable from the
redistribution of keys and I also want
that the live and function between H
prime under the fake hash key and F
which I simply defined as H prime under
KF plus FX model two so I want that the
image of this correlation function is
exponential e-sports in the range okay
and I'm going to say that in such a case
H prime with the fake hash key and F
have a sparse correlation so again I
moved from looking at the function edge
to looking at the function H prime plus
F and then claiming that if these two
properties hold if I have a distribution
or fake hash keys for every function f
that is indistinguishable that is
indistinguishable from the real hash key
and if the correlation between H prime
under the fake hash key and F is sparse
enough
and I'm claiming that we get that H is a
coalition and to see this notice that
that the probability that they exist on
X such that H of X is equal to f of X
namely the probability that the existing
relation is equal to the probability
that H prime of X plus f of X is equal
to or I just switched sides here and
this means that the probability that
there exists the correlation is equal to
the probability that R is inside the
image of this sporulation function there
are a couple of questions people are
asking so you're doing more to
operations here so is the string R and H
prime K of X is that a multi-bit string
or you're just computing over in I mean
is it like a bit mean more to over
vectors or you're doing over the entire
integer space yes so these are two
binary vectors and I'm just doing
bitwise addition obviously to okay
this is just or okay again this is a
vector this is another vector both are
binary vectors I'm just exploring both
bit by bit
yeah thank you
okay and this choice is arbitrary again
you can do the these metrics and these
arguments over the integers to
participants returns okay I'm I can take
questions
so is another way to see this merely
that you want H prime of X to be close
to f of X notice that this this this
this is not necessarily around zero okay
and in fact if okay so from the one hand
we want that KF is indistinguishable
from K and one way to see it to say this
is to say that KF hides F in some sense
you know intuitively at least H K sub F
cannot be close to F because then it may
reveal something about F so this this
image is not necessarily centered
centered at zero but we require that
there are very few possible values for
these two for this for this okay so H H
prime not necessarily close to F but as
opposed to some shift if that's them
some shift or it won't be ship it with
this shift you're talking about has to
be somehow cryptographically hidden so
it's not that simple but so again this
this image is it's not right it's not
really having a cycle inside inside
simply it's simply a way to say that the
image is sports e okay thanks okay any
other questions
cool okay and now I think I convinced
you that if these two hold then we get
that H is Somerset's calculation
injectable so again I reduced my goal
from constructing Croatian tractability
to getting this kind of sparse
correlation between H Prime and F yes I
see there's another question
okay so again I will go or now is to
construct sparse correlations rather
than correlation stackable hash perfect
and now I'm going to show you how to do
that under standard assumptions good and
I'm going to start with a very modest
goal of constructing sparse correlations
for linear functions I'm going to take
linear functions over z2 okay so a
linear function is simply defined by a
matrix again we're interested in
pressing functions so it's going to be a
fat matrix so it's going to take inputs
a offering and and map them to input of
length M and the picture looks like that
good and the construction I'm going to
show you is under DDH and then I'm going
to say that it can be generalized to be
constructed on under other standard
assumptions but let's for now focus on
the gauge construction so they actually
work in a setting where there's a
multiplicative prime or the group G and
there's a public generator small G this
group and I'm going to use the additive
notation so whenever you see that I'm
adding two group elements then what I
actually mean is that I'm multiplying
this tool when I'm multiplying an
integer with a group element that I mean
to take this element to the power of
offices in genomic language and I'm
going to be really crazy about a
different ation I'm going to even add
group elements with integers and what I
mean by G 1 plus Z and this case is G 1
times G to the see I try to make this as
as little confusion as possible and this
notation in particular allows me to
multiply matrix of group elements so now
I have a matrix of group elements of
length M over m to multiply it by a
vector of integers or particularly a
binary vector so when I multiply this
matrix with this binary vector I I'm
gonna get a vector of group elements
again according to this notation any
questions regarding this good okay so
what Y can be read H useful for
constructing sports correlations so one
of one application of the DTH assumption
is that rank one matrices are
indistinguishable from general random
matrices more specifically if I take a
random matrix of group elements where
the exponents form a rank one matrix so
the vectors here in the exponent or just
multiples of our scalar multiples of
some random vector or then the DTH
assumption tells us that this random
rank one matrix is indistinguishable
from a matrix that I sampled totally
okay this is a pretty standard so again
I know that random rank one matrices of
a group elements are indistinguishable
from totally random matrices of group
elements and why are rank one matrices
are useful or interesting in our case
notice that sample nice to see it have a
sparse image okay this is a high school
algebra if you take a rank one matrix
and multiply it by an integer vector and
you will get the image of our X is
sports in the domain G 2 by M in this
case and idea like you can guess is to
construct the hash function where the
correlation function that we get between
H with a fake hash key and F is a rank
one function
any questions so this is the high-level
idea now I'm going to show you how to
actually implement it so based on this
idea I'm going to define or at least as
a first attempt I'm going to define my
hash function as follows
so my hash key is just a random matrix
of group elements of size M over N and
I'm going to denote it by K and we take
an input to the hash and we simply
multiply it by K to get a vector of
group elements this is my hash function
is pretty simple okay this is the Isle
of pictures so this is the picture put a
hash function so now let's try and
define the fake hash key for a function
f in the class to be the storm of a
random rank one matrix and the function
that the matrix defined by the function
if okay so again I have a distribution
of fake affair in hash keys which is
simply which simply samples a random
matrix of group elements and now I'm
defining the fake distribution for a
function f in the class and this is I'm
confused by something very very basic
which is where's the multiplication
where's the matrix multiplication
happening like matrix multiplication
requires addition and multiplication
right and right
it's a group so right so okay so so what
is that this this is this vectors in the
plane right and this matrix is in the
exponent but you can always so this
vector consists of zeros and one and
basically so let's say I'm multiplying
the first row here with the column here
so whatever I have the one I will add
the corresponding group elements to the
multiplication I see so it's all
happening in the exponent I say I see
okay it's having exponent but because
one of the sides is in the plane you can
all you're doing here is multiplying
bits with
elements this is doable and then lastly
you just add whatever you like right
I can't evoke meaning get multi-plane
groupings yes good so again okay so I
told you how to simply add it hash key
and now I'm telling you how to sample a
fake hash key for some function in the
class and in order to sample a fake hash
key for F I'm sampling a random rank one
matrix or and I'm adding the matrix
defined by the function f and what this
essentially means is the following so
I'm taking a random rank one matrix and
I'm adding the the matrix of group
elements that has the entries of the
function in the exponent so if F 1 2 F M
are the rows in B the matrix defined by
F then this matrix I'm looking at is G
to the F 1 due to the f2 etc this 2 here
is by mistake so just ignore it and
again adding these two matrices meaning
getting this matrix on the left so every
row here is some scalar multiplication
of random row R plus the Darrow defined
by the function
any questions
okay and remember the first thing I
required from fake cash keys that they
are indistinguishable from real keys
real hash keys and we know that under D
D H this matrix is indistinguishable
from random matrix and therefore also
this matrix plus F is indistinguishable
from them is there a question
yeah I have a question can you repeat
what is this matrix for F again so F was
a function from some domain to a single
bit right no so f is a is this linear
function that is defined by a matrix
right so so again my target class now is
a linear function so I want to construct
correlations apt ability for linear
functions linear functions how are they
defined generally by a matrix item over
and they take a vector of length n
uncompress it to a vector of length M so
this is a binary matrix and I write just
methods of zeros and one and what I'm
saying is that in the hash key
I want to embed the description of the
function but I do it in the exponent
okay because I'm working with group
elements here so my fake hash key we're
going is going to be a this random ran
on matrix and I'm going to add in the
exponent the entries of F
okay
but isn't a function defined over z2 but
here it's right so okay so again the
function itself is defined over z2 but
this math fix it doesn't contain zeros
and one but rather it contains group
elements and more specifically wherever
I have a one in the function fiction I'm
going to have a G right there generator
G to the one is D whatever I have is
here I'm going to have a one which is an
element of the group because it's just G
to the zero so this this becomes the
matrix of group elements and what what
essentially I'm doing here is taking
event one in matrix or group elements
and adding to it the description of the
function over the prime of the row and
I'm going to end up with a matrix of
this form but doing this over z2
wouldn't be same as growing it in the
exponent of this group right say again
so if you are actually computing this
function over Z 2 and here you are
computing because over the exponent of
this group but those things won't be the
same because you can add two once and
you give it to here but you'll get a
zero there definitely so you already see
one problem in this construction and
that's why it's called a temp 1 notice
that so what actually is saying is that
now if I want if I would like to
multiply this matrix of group elements
by some vector X then the
multiplications are going to be sorry
the automatics is going to be model 2 P
the order of the group present then
rather than model 2 and that is correct
and other questions so again think about
messing around matrix and they also
multiply by G the entries that
correspond to one in the description of
F
is that clear now okay if there are any
questions please ask
we have been offline cool okay and like
I said under the assumption this
distribution of feta cheese looks
indistinguishable from a random
distribution of a free piece and that's
because this kind of ramp one is
indistinguishable from a random matrix
under addition with AF doesn't change
anything
so yes yeah
surfer stupid question but why couldn't
use KF as your hash key done sure has
okay
so notice that my goal is to construct
relation to have ability for an entire
class I'm I when I when I define a
collection tractable - I'm not sure
which function the adversary may choose
to attack so my goal and if this is
essential is to construct -
acceptability against the entire class
we saw before that construction closures
at will for a single function is
actually easy so we're not interested in
this case we're interested to construct
relations octave built against and enjoy
class and one way to do it is to be find
a fake hash key for every function and
then claim possession that ability under
the fake hash key for every function
I hope this answers your question
so again we have that we were
construction questions against the class
of linear functions and this fact key it
appears only in the proof of collision
testability it doesn't appear in the
reconstruction the reconstruction simply
samples a random hash key okay so so
time and a question this is you note the
trivial construction would be you know
for a single function would be compute
the function and add one or something
like that right yeah but then the
description of the hash key depends you
know it reveals reveals direction if you
say that you know what let's I don't
want you know a correlation tractor for
a class of functions I just want it for
a single function but the key has to
hide F is that also trivial or is it
trivial you know if it's not trivial is
it useful you know what does it mean to
hide F if there's only one F good
question you know in the applications
for example right you once you fix a
protocol don't you actually know what
the function is and even so for the
public key for the commitment scheme you
know isn't the F fixed so once so once
you fix so okay so but the function will
contain the secret key underlying the
commitment not reveal right but you want
that okay so notice that so okay so what
I'm missing here
so I guess this is what you're doing is
one way to formalize you know this this
requirement you know that looking at the
key you can't tell what the function is
I'm just wondering if there is a way to
sort of do it with achill computational
you know III see what you mean so you're
saying I have equal you're saying okay
we have considable - for some function
that hi so the hash key hides laughs I
think it wouldn't work for Mystics but
if you can simply hash key for every F
and still high def then you can simple
hash key for a bounded function right
and get little bit for reckless so you
know one wait so you know what were it
so Chris was asking what does it mean to
hide F right here's one way to do it one
way to think about it
you know if I give you the hash key
right it should be it's a very sort of
tailored definition it should be hard to
do something for example sort of break
the hiding of a commitments game so
that's one way to say formalize what it
means to hide right that should be
sufficient for an easy case that's what
you're saying right yes but but I'm
saying maybe if you can do that then you
already have the construction of
stability for an entire class simply
stand fairly hashkee for redundant
function the zero function
okay thanks for the questions okay so
now I saw I showed you that for every
function that exists a distribution over
fake hash key is indistinguishable from
the redistribution of hash keys and what
it means to show you that this fake hash
key defines a sparse correlation then
with the function itself this
essentially will will employ coalition
stability like so what is the how does
the first function look under the fake
hash key so what playing the fake key
with an input X is simply consists of
two parts so the first power
is all x x plus f of X and this plus
again is over the group and if we switch
sides then you can see that again this
is very high level but the hash function
will be fake hash key on X minus and
this minus again is over the group f of
X in the exponent is equal to some rank
one computation ramp one matrix
multiplied by X so if we if this is our
kind of correlation function and notice
that it does define some correlation
between the fake hash and s then this
function has a sparse image right sparse
population so it seems that we are very
close to achieving our goal and the only
problem and I think people already
noticed it is that this correlation is
over G and it considers the computation
of F over the exponent so first of all
the computation is not in the pain and
second the computation is not modulo two
but rather modulo P so we're getting
there this is not quite what we need any
questions
good so the idea is to translate all
these computations that are performed
over the group G to computation over Z -
okay as a second attempt to construct
our hash function I'm going to assume we
have this magic tool that I'm going to
call patent coding over G that takes a
group element G to the C and outputs the
parity of its exponent is mo Duru
I see we have a question
yes so previously you mentioned you you
want to compute the image from the group
element to Z to Wooster so what's the
purpose of that okay so again our main
goal is to to get a correlation function
between hash with the fake key and F
that has a sports image and like I
showed here we we have some kind of a
correlation function between H under the
fake T and F but this collection
function it considers the correlation
between the hash and the function when
it's computed in the exponent notice
notice that this file if this matrix is
a matrix of group elements right if we
go back then the function here is
described that description of the
function is embedded into the exponent
so the person I'm getting here is
between the hash with the fake T and the
function in the exponent and you may say
well maybe this is just some practical
issue that's not really a problem but
then so so this function it relates to
our Sigma protocol and it basically
defines the bad challenge function
though right so it's not really clear
how to take such sparse correlation and
use it to claim correlation that ability
and Sigma protocol where all the
computations are done in the plane so
you would you would choir some form some
some something that will take this value
and translate it into and converts it
into f of X it's not really clear how to
do that so in other words there might be
a way that if the if function is defined
alternatively say the image is also a
group element then we may be stuck there
yes but again this is not only a
syntactical issue it's not only working
over G versus working over G to working
over G by itself introduces this right
introduces the cryptographic hiding
we're getting from bead edge so this
this is saying that you cannot actually
see f of X and maybe it's inherent that
you need that the computation of a dash
of the bad challenge is actually in the
play and can be seen by developer rhythm
but I don't think it's purely
syntactical okay cool so again our goal
is to take somehow translate all these
automatics to computations over z2 and
I'm going to assume a magic function
which I'm going to call the path
encoding over in my group G that takes
any group element G to the Z and outputs
the parity of the integer Z in the
exponent okay and I'm sure many of you
already think that this is impossible
assuming did H because if we if this can
be computed efficiently then we
essentially break the assumption and
this is true but for now let's assume we
have such a function that takes K to the
Z and output the least significant bit
of Z and now my hash function will be
defined exactly as before but now I'm
going to take this vector of group
elements and compute its parity so now
rather than outputting G to the Y which
is essentially the product of K
multiplied by X I'm going to output Y
modulo 2
and now again I'm going to sample the
Takashi as before and we already saw
that K sub F multiplied by X consists of
our X which is a lamp on matrix
multiplied by X plus f of X in the
exponent but now I apply a parity to
this to this map and what I will get is
the parity of our x plus f of X and now
this f of X is over z2 rather than over
that Adam would loopy and now what I get
is that the correlation between the hash
with the fake key on X and FX is equal
to the Perico for X and because our X
has a sparse image so does the pedicle
Phonics
good so now I got what I needed I needed
that the correlation between the real F
in the plane and the hash with the fake
key is sparse and this is true in this
case Julie
question so so yeah you you also you
don't want F to wrap up not P right so
you want the coefficients of F to be
small is that is that correct yes yes so
the coefficients of another questions
maybe you said this and Mister what do
you mean by parity here do you mean to
being the hardcore bit of the oh no so
I'm assuming so this encoding doesn't
exist
at least you cannot compute it
efficiently if you don't want to break
this edge but the parity here is just
taking a group element so the fact is is
defined according to the generator G so
essentially you take a group element and
you output a parity of its discrete log
that's what essentially it was okay so
petty just the patio of the discrete log
of a group element okay thank you and
again if this property if I can I can
compute parity efficiently then my hash
function that I define as before plus
this parity encoding it defines this
parse correlation between the hash with
a shaky and for every F any more
questions so like I already mentioned a
couple of times if parity if I can
compute this part encoding efficiently
then I essentially break the assumption
so we were gonna have to find a better
way to compute this encoding and oh
we're going to use an idea that so that
was first used by boy b-boy and I show
you two in a different in a way
different context and so so what what I
essentially do there is so just a way to
compute
what they call a distributed discrete
log of group elements and we use the
essentially the same ideas to compute a
different parity encoding so now we do
not require that the parity encoding
outputs the parity of the discrete log
but rather we require a much simpler and
weaker property the only thing we
require from the parity encoding is that
it preserved preserves the difference
between the parity of different group
elements so we require that if we take a
group element H then the parity of H and
the parity of H multiplied by some G to
the Y is equal to the a parity of Y
okay and we require that this holds true
for for bounded values of ROI and I'm
not going to go into the details but I
think it's not that hard to be convinced
that this is the only property that we
use in the ideas I just described in the
construction so again our construction
of a hash of the Christian hash simply
multiplying this random matrix of group
elements by the input and then applying
the parity encoding which I'm going to
describe in a bit but this pallet
encoding is no longer this parrot
encoding it doesn't output the LSB of
the disk of the discrete log but it's
rather an encoding that preserves the
difference between the asperities of the
discrete logs of two group elements any
questions
okay so I told you that computing the
parity of the discrete globe is hard
because you cannot okay Chris question
yeah just just to make sure I understand
so are you just using the fact that so
you've got this hidden Rx in in there
and then you've also got the F times X
in there right
and we're taking the parity of the sum
of these two things and so is like the
RX playing the role of H here in some
way is that how I should think of it
okay
and so we get the parity of f of X but
kind of shifted by this unknown so Y
here is f of X yes okay and then the
polynomial bounded Y has to do with
because f of X is not automatically not
- right but it's a small integer yes
okay awesome thank you any more
questions
perfect okay so okay the animations are
buggy here in the slide so I'm gonna
show everything okay so I'm going to
take
go back to the first step
I think I showed that I claimed is
cannot be computed differently so and I
told you that it's essentially it
essentially all puts the parity of
discrete look and one way to interpret
this computation is as follows let's
look at the line of group elements that
starts with one then G G square and so
on and now I'm saying that in order to
compute the parity or some group element
H which is equal to G to the T just
start working on this line until you
reach one so walking Li is just dividing
by G over and over again and you walk
over this line until you until you reach
one and the number of steps is going to
take you until you reach one is clearly
the discrete log of this H and now I
tell you once you reach one take the
parity of the number of steps so the
point of H is essentially the parity of
the number of steps to reach one and
this in this interpretation
okay so this is another very inefficient
way to compute the initially computable
pallet encoding okay well why do I show
you this because now I'm going to
suggest a bit different way to compute a
pallet encoding in a way that I preserve
the property that I was talking so now
I'm not going to compute the discrete
log and take its parity but rather I'm
going to compute the distribute
distributed this big book and what does
it say so we say the following let's
define a set of group elements using
some PRF so I'm taking a random
pseudo-random function and I'm defining
a set of reference points over this line
of group elements to be all group
elements that map to 0 under this pseudo
random function ok so this is just an
arbitrary random set of group elements
over this line of group elements and now
I'm saying instead of walking on this
line until you reach one walk until you
reach the closest reference point so in
this case if you start with edge and you
start walking
meaning dividing by G over and over
again then you're going to reach Z 2 and
let's say this takes you keep right
steps so now that Perico H is going to
be defined as the parity of this T prime
so now the parity is not it's not only
the parity of steps it takes to reach
women but rather the number the effect
of number of steps it takes you to reach
the closest reference point okay
so again this is our new parity encoding
and I claim that the parity of H times G
to the Y plus the parity of H is equal
to Y and this is all we needed for our
sparse population and why is this true
notice that H and H times G to the Y if
Y is sufficiently small the
are kind of close to each other and now
the number of stiff t-prime was the
number of steps it took H to reach Z 2
and then the number of steps it will
take H times due to the wise he prime
plus y and the part of this plus the
pareto this is exactly the pallet of a 1
this is some simple simple map simple
calculation now this is true but not
always there's this a stick here
notice that when I had a red reference
point between H and H times G to the
wire and everything here fails so this
is true as long as I don't have any red
points between these two green points
the only question
not a question Tommy but just to give
you a quick time check you have about
five minutes left
oh really okay we can a little bit but
here just to give you a big time check
I'll try to speed stuff okay so you've
got to believe me that if if the number
of Z's is if we have just a quite right
amount of reference points over this
line then we will we will get that we
will get correctness with high
probability we will get this probability
holes with high probability but on the
other hand the algorithm will be
efficient because the closest deference
point will be would be indeed close to H
okay are there any questions on that
okay so again to wrap it up our hash
function simply multiplies by a random
matrix of group elements and then
applies this 30 according to the to the
vector of group elements element element
okay so all of these ideas can be
extracted yes you do
are you I'm going to explain how to deal
with the error right so there will be a
inverse polynomial error here if you're
and if you're still not convinced that
this is not the problem
by the end of the talk okay so notice
this this probability is high but it's
not it's not the overwhelming okay it's
not one minus negative builets one minus
one okay Polly I'm sure it would be
clear
so again one of these ideas can be
abstracted using a new primitive which
is called a trap - that was originally
used for information retrieval and it
can be constructed under the age but
also under true or this oil and lwe and
we can very easily bootstrap this to
support constant decay polynomials and
not only linear functions so now we know
that under these standard assumptions we
have collation tractability for constant
degree polynomials which is already
something but notice and now I bring
back over outline I will always come
stock musics for NP and for this we know
we have to construct relation
tractability for the bad challenge
function but all we get now under these
under assumptions escalation
tractability for constant degree
polynomials and it doesn't seem that the
bachelors function can be described as a
constant degree polynomial in in any
Sigma protocol that we know so this is
not sufficient for music not yet so now
we ask whether can we get more from this
sparse correlations paradigm so let's go
back to the sparse correlation thing and
we observe that so we claimed
correlation intractability because we
said if we suffered a random or and if I
were a correlation sparse then this R is
with negligible probability and the
sports image of the correlation function
but we observe we observe that it's not
only that our is not in the image with
overwhelming probability but rather our
is far from the sports image with
overwhelming probability so if we take
the Hamming ball around all than with
overwhelming probability it does not
intersect with the with the said image
of the sports correlation what does this
mean practically this means so I'm not
going to go through the math because
we're short bit short on time but this
means that it's not only hard to find
correlation between H of X and f of X an
exact correlation but rather it's hard
to find a correlation for any
approximation of the function f so it's
hard to find an X such that H of X and f
of X are not only equal but are even
close
okay and this leads us to define this
stronger notion of question testability
which we call CI for approximable
relations or CI aprox for short which
I'm going to talk about next so what do
we mean by saying that some hash
function H is correlation tractability
correlation approximable by a function f
or CI aprox who f would say that h is
such a function when when when any
adversary cannot find a an X such that H
of X and f of X are close in Hamming
distance okay so this requirement it's
stronger than relation tractability but
now we what it allows us to consider
simpler classes of functions and I want
to say that this notion is it's not a
new notion of collation tractability a
just correlation tractability for
approximable relations and rather than
search table relations so these are
relations that do not only contain X and
f of X but rather contain X and the
hammock ball around okay anyway again we
say that a hash function is boxed for a
function class if itself dogs for
everyone
and from what I explained in Isla del it
holds that if we can instantiate this
past correlation paradigm then we get CI
aprox full function class F so what does
this mean so it means that under the
standard assumptions did H ol Q or this
essentially under standard assumption
that gives you a blue hash you can get a
CI aprox for constant decay polynomials
so now we don't get collisions activity
or constantly prolong yawns but rather
we get collision tractability for
approximable relations by constructive
constant degree polynomials okay and
this is way stronger as it appears then
just crushing tractability were
constantly given almost but not it so
clear how powerful this notion is unless
we quantify it using sets of elevations
because that's essentially what we're
looking for so and to do this to
understand the power of relational aprox
let's consider this standard notion of
approximation so I'm going to say that a
function class F has a probabilistic
representation by a much simple simply a
class C if we're every function in this
F I can sample a random function C such
that for any X with overwhelming
probability I'm going f of X is going to
be very close to C of X ok so again I
have a function
that for every X distribution some
distribution over functions in C get you
that C of X and f of X
close with overwhelming probability okay
this is a very standard motions and one
of the more important theorems in this
world is that if F has a probablistic
representation by C then C I approach
for AC immediately implies correlation
tractability
for the class F and again we hope that
this Class C is much simpler than this
class F and this means that in order to
a construct relationship ability for a
powerful and expressive class F all we
need is to construct CI aprox for a most
simple class of functions C and this is
made of implies that under the
management assumptions we have
correlation tractability for all
functions that have probabilistic
constant degree representation and to
give you some sense about the power of
this statement I just want to say and
this is pretty standard that CNF
formulas have probablistic once and the
gable presentation so we already get
collation acceptability for CNF formulas
under standard assumptions other than
Allah Mui
the proof is not that hard so I'm going
to skip it yes and questions
okay so the proof of this theorem is
simple and intuitive so again the our
outline now looks like that so we
started in with that the ration we were
able to construct CI aprox for constant
degree functions and this what this
theorem tells us is that this gives us
correlation tractable - for functions
that can be probably sztyc Lehrer
presented by constant degree polynomials
and now the only thing we have left to
do is to show that but challenge has
probabilistic representation as constant
degree polynomials and why are we hope
that such a prolific representation
exists because we know that this class
of functions already captures KCF and
maybe by challenge can be described
using a case and CNF formulas and maybe
some other
so any questions good so what I'm going
to show you real quick next is that
under LPN under the open assumption we
have a sigma protocol protocol where the
bad challenge function has a
probabilistic one centigrade
representation and if we do that we
faint yes so again just to go back a bit
so my goal now is to show you that under
the LP assumption there exists a sigma
protocol where the Bachelet function has
a wholistic constant video presentation
and all I'm going to say in this regard
is if we take the commitment open Sigma
protocol that we've seen before where
the bachelors function is simply some
poly time verification algorithm applied
over the extracted values that we
extract from the first message then ok
and now we observe that or we use the
fact that CNF satisfiability is complete
for the parlament amplification okay
this is a simple this is simply some
very special case of the cook-levin
theorem ok I'm not going to go through
the details but we can just the protocol
a bit any comic and open Sigma protocol
we can take it and adjust it a bit using
the cochlear an idea of appending a
witness to turning essentially any
polynomial time purification to a brief
occasion of the satisfiability of some
case and a formula by appending a coke
living witness so we do that and we get
a protocol where the bachelors function
is now not any people not an arbitrary
polynomial term computation over the
accepted value but is rather simply a
face and a formula over the extracted
values okay so now our bad falling a
challenge function consists of first
extracting the values on the line
ments and then applying fish and a
formula and now okay so using standards
and randomization techniques you can
show that the fish and egg formulas can
be politically represented by equals and
degree polynomials and further we show
that under the FBN assumption there
exists a commitment scheme which is
acceptable and where the extraction
function can be probablistic represented
by linear functions so these are of
course we know means of degree one so
combining these two facts we we we can
apply that the this bachelors function
has four basic representation by
constantly pulling audience okay and now
we can complete a picture and say that
under eight pm there exists a sigma
protocol where the badge challenge
function term has promised to be
constantly people longer and therefore
we can use our construction of collation
tractable hash which has security on the
particular bdh okay so there are many
open questions of course the con can ask
here in particular one can ask whether
there are other applications of this new
collection capability for approximate
approximate relations framework it may
be applications to ducks or to some
theory results another question may be
is whether we can minimize the set of
assumptions on which we base the
security of our protocol and also
whether we can get statistical zero
knowledge maybe or an easy proof rather
than just the arguments which all
protocols with the computational service
that's it thanks and happy to take a
question
have a question so if you is that is the
bootstrapping from coalition
tractability for linear relation to a
constant relation generic specific yes
so so I can just explain it in one
sentence you simply take so a constant a
function is simply a linear function
over the tensor of your input right over
some constant degree terms of your input
so instead of applying the hash function
on your input you apply it over the
tensor of your so that's the so also the
bootstrapping of the approximation also
happens here
so the approximation doesn't affect the
quickness of what I said the
bootstrapping can be even done in the
trap door - leveled so so it can be
either done in the tabla house level or
in the coalition with the construction
and simply lock ok cool things I have a
question so does this probably sticker
presentation satisfy this composability
property that if you have probably stick
references probabilistic constant agree
representation of F and G and F composed
with G also has this probably stick or
chandelier presentation
yes but one has to be careful there are
many technicalities here that I kind of
I didn't mention but in general yes
publicity visitation is composable but
we're dealing here with also with
extraction of commitments which can be
also invalid so there are lots of
technicalities that one has to be
careful with here
I hope I answered your question so if
there are no other questions then it's
not made for the talk we will be having
the second seminar on Tuesday so thanks
I've been ready for joining in today
time somewhere thanks thanks so much
thank you know so we'll just stop the
recording right now we'll just stop the
recording right no way